be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the various cosmic
entities of the all-new all-different
mobile prime universe starting with
colitis now what I'm hoping is that at
the end of all this you'll have a strong
understanding of his character relative
to the number of issues that we have as
well as how his involvement in the new
universe actually helps us to understand
how things relate to the pre secret wars
universe
so the all-new all-different Galactus
comes to us as part of Al Ewing's
all-new all-different Ultimates and
while I will have a video on that team
as part of a lead-up to civil war to
what Al Ewing does here is actually
really interesting to sidetrack for a
second when Galactus first debuted in
the original Marvel Universe while he
wasn't provided an origin in his first
few appearances the explanation of his
existence came by way of Thor vol 1
issues 168 through 170 originally
established as being a universal
Explorer named Galan in the earth co
continuity at the end of that universes
life Galactus remained the sole survivor
merging with that reality's version of
eternity during this birthing process
Galactus it fashioned a vessel for
himself allowing an incubation period of
several million years where he gathered
his energies constructed a suit to
contain those energies and emerged as a
Galactus that we all know and love
consuming planets to sustain his life
now all the reasons for Galactus being a
cosmic necessity have changed over the
years ranging from a meta commentary on
his representation of life death and
rebirth as well as a physical force
whose death unleashed Abraxas who
threatened the multiverse on the whole a
Ewing does not actually provide us with
an expansive origin and the Marvel prime
universe while there are different
explanations that could be offered for
this and truth I would surmise that with
Galactus being such a well-known
character even if his origin is only
slightly understood by casual readers
it's still understood and so the
information provided actually just gives
us a one-page synopsis sticking with a
classic story of Galactus hailing from
the earth zero continuity and that said
because the Ultimates exist to in threat
to the universe but to also boost fan
anticipation for the start of the series
the first being encountered by The
Ultimates came in the form of Galactus
taking place in issues number one and
number two in November and December of
2015 as the official launch title and a
self-contained story what we're told
is that from the perspective of blue
Marvel and Black Panther Galactus is
hunger is not a requirement for him
instead this is a byproduct of the
incubation period meaning this process
could be reversed now somebody take note
of here is that al Ewing is taking
certain liberties and that as far as I'm
aware the hunger of Galactus is an
intrinsic part of his character and no
one had ever created a story where his
hunger was depicted as something that
could be cured the only exception to
this that I can think of came in the
first six issues of the 2003 Thanos solo
series by jim Starlin which depicted
Galactus as hunger as a multiversal
entity working through Galactus and
attempting to consume realities however
because this story arch stretched the
limits of credulity even by comic
standards fans don't generally consider
it to be canon or in existence now in
terms of The Ultimates after putting
their efforts together Black Panther and
blue Marvel reasoned that if Galactus is
hunger emerged following his time in the
incubation chamber the hunger could be
reversed by forcing Galactus back into
the chamber to this end the Ultimates
backtrack alack toises time as a
devourer of worlds eventually arriving
at our key Opia the first planet
Galactus it consumed after emerging
scavenging the dead world and
reconstructing the incubation chamber
the entirety of the Ultimates including
Carol Danvers Monica Rambeau America
Chavez and black panther combined their
powers in an effort to force Galactus
back into his chamber emerging as a life
bringer at the conclusion of issue
number 2 al Ewing established that
instead of consuming worlds and ending
life Galactus now functions as the
source of life creating in healing
worlds he had previously consumed
beginning with our key obeah following
this and going into the next five titles
leading up to issue number seven as the
most current release the Ultimates line
serves to provide two plots the first
following the Ultimates themselves and
leading into Civil War two with a second
following Galactus and an explanation of
the all-new all-different model prime
universe picking up an issue number four
following the Ultimates attempts to
understand the space-time continuum in
the post secret wars continuity Galactus
himself was contacted by eternity who
advised of the ultimate actions and that
they could not proceed visiting the team
omits their journey into the previous
realm of the beyonders which now exists
as a void of nothingness a viewing
begins the first steps of referencing
the pre secret wars universe
where carol danvers offers the
explanation that the team sought to
understand the space-time continuum
Galactus provides her with a glimpse of
how he sees time establishing that were
model had never officially provided an
answer the fact remains that secret Wars
was not a reboot instead the event took
place in the earth-616 universe still
happened but secret Wars
allowed for a reshuffling of characters
in realities this comes with the fact
that as Galactus shows us the death of
the original Captain Marvel the Iron Man
armor Wars and the onslaught saga are
memories that he still maintains at the
same time he also makes reference to
Marvel sliding time scale and the idea
of red Khan's
to sidetrack with Marvel's publications
it was standard practice for them to
include dates and references to
presidents throughout the 1960s and
1970s but with the 1980s seeing their
final reference to a concrete period in
the real world from that point going
forward all absolute dates of reference
were eliminated what this meant was that
instead of saying Civil War happened in
a certain year and during a certain
month instead the event would take place
with future stories referencing it as a
year or three years ago as a result
between 1984 and the current day
everything within Marvel comics is
assumed to have taken place within a
10-year window in addition to this
Galactus states that the past is never
concrete and then it can always be
changed now this is really more of a
meta commentary on retroactive
continuities and the idea that various
writers will alter the history of models
past in order to suit an existing story
or to introduce a character as an
example within the Marvel Universe
itself
blue Marvel did not exist until 2009
when Kevin Bravo had created him and
altered the history of Marvel to
establish that Adam Brashear was
Marvel's first black superhero now while
I do have a video explaining these
concepts in more detail for those who
still find them a little confusing with
a Galactus forcing the heroes to sleep
and returning them to the main universe
he's called before eternity who reveals
that he's being kept in Chains and was
placed in this position by an unknown
being now something actually want to do
here is I want to step away from this
for a minute and I want to have a
discussion on the role of eternity in
the new Marvel prime universe within the
old universe eternity existed as a
singular being and a physical
manifestation of each universe that
existed
however because doom had created
battleworld during Secret Wars while the
planet was composed of different
realities instead of battleworld having
a version of eternity for each territory
the whole of battle world combined to
allow for singular entity who was kept
under the control of dooms power now
this is particularly important due to
the fact that the fan community was
largely split over the idea of a
multiversal version of eternity existing
under the Living Tribunal and serving to
represent the multiverse itself holding
it all together while the idea of a
multiverse eternity was alluded to but
never really confirmed prior to and
during Secret Wars with Al Ewing's
Ultimates his information reveals that
after the destruction of battle world
and the creation of the multiverse by
Owen Reese Franklin Richards and Reed
Richards a multiverse all eternity came
into existence
holding the multiverse together under
the New Living Tribunal and spawning the
cosmic entities and so with a multiverse
itself in Chains Galactus was tasked
with discovering who it was it did this
and how to restore things to normal
picking up with issue number six where
Galactus continues his quest as it was
assigned by eternity during his travels
he encounters master order and Lord
chaos as the representations of order
and chaos who work against one another
then maintain universal balance through
their conflict because Galactus had
previously been known as the world
devourer to the mind of Lord chaos
Galactus represented destruction and
catastrophe but for master order the
destruction of Galactus was part of the
cosmic order allowing for the death of
planets and the balance of the universal
population but because he has vacated
that role and stepped into the position
of the life bringer Lord chaos is no
longer satisfied due to Galactus failing
to inflict destruction the master order
is unsatisfied due to Galactus stepping
away from the status quo to this end the
entities transported Galactus to the
SuperFlow which existed as a space
between realities with the intention of
forcing Galactus back into his position
however because master order and Lord
chaos exists in such rigid forms with
Galactus maintaining free will the two
entities are completely overpowered and
forced to retreat after which Galactus
is brought before Owen Reese the
molecule man now for this bit of the
discussion what we have previously
engaged in a bit of meta commentary the
conversation between Galactus and Owen
Reese is extremely important due to the
that molecule man will actually address
the reader base directly and the
community's view of the all-new
all-different universe
what molecule man gets extremely wordy
and goes as far as to use a modified
version of the Schrodinger's cat thought
experiment the long and short of this is
that molecule man addresses the issue of
model existing in a state of flux decide
track here the thought experiment of
Schrodinger's cat is a concept in
quantum mechanics offering the idea that
if an unobserved action occurs any and
all possibilities of that action are
available however once that observation
occurs an absolute answer is provided
and the question is definitively
answered while this may seem a little
confusing to simplify things molecule
man is saying that the problem with the
current universe is that it was rebooted
but it wasn't rebooted furthermore there
are some beings within the universe who
do not remember the events of the
multiverse or collapse and Sucher wars
but there are also some who do as a
result there are those who believed that
the multiverse did collapse and was
recreated but there are also those that
don't
but what al Ewing is doing here is
offering a statement to us and Marvell
saying that you can't have it both ways
you can't shuffle some characters around
introduce new teams and offer
conflicting memories all while calling
it a reboot if you haven't actually
rebooted anything either it's a reboot
or it's not that said because we're only
seven issues into the series we don't
know what direction the story will take
or work of Octus will end up but because
each number seven focuses entirely on
the actions of Thanos as part of the
lead-up to Civil War two we're actually
going to go ahead and in this video
right here but with that being said let
me know how you guys feel about all-new
all-different marvel because I think
it's kind of cool some of the things
that are doing but I think that some of
the things you're doing could also use
some changes anyway I will catch you
guys on it peace